this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
you know what's funny bro
how long what bro you and I you were I'm
in a bad mood I'm in a bad mood you came
in a bad mood for a variety of reasons
yeah I spilled Diet Coke all over myself
I sat down I was talking to George went
and but you know that's a that's a Hanes
t-shirt and that's the thing right so
that's kind of it doesn't matter just
sucks I go through the whole day with
this you should rip it you should go
like this and rip it off and then just
uh and then do the podcast with your
shirt off you know what I realized you
know what's funny is that um so you and
I fight right now why are you sitting up
like shut up shut up sitting like this
because I'm because I'm feeling you're
free risky bro and prickly okay now let
me ask you something
right now you and I go at it for real
you're gonna you kill me right we know
this right well documented yeah yeah
well what what do you ask me what do you
think I'll do what do you think you do
grab whatever you want no whatever you
want look at how casual you are right
yeah
and and yet hey
can you bring up the post I just did let
me just because y'all Mustafa forgot hey
Jin bring up exhibit a when the ref
decides to take a little
break well I'm pounding away let me let
me see this the ref goes you know I'm
gonna check out the the ring card girls
while Brendan Daddy's doing work now
turn up the volume for me so you can
hear the sound of these thuds
can you make it big chin or no
[Applause]
ah Jesus that's that's Brennan who has
to wait hold on oh Jesus just stop the
fight
stop the fight dude that that is a
terrible rap
you gave that guy brain damage Jesus
Christ Brendan killed a guy oh dude you
might want to lay low for a little bit
that rough was like this stop the fight
dummy that reference
Celeste was like holy sh oh God that man
that ref is a [__] oh God someone said
uh that ref hey you suck ref whoever
that ref is what a bad guy well I just
don't think you know this is back in the
day what's hilarious about that is that
you that I'm not bullshitting you you
would never get that off never you know
why now did I do that to a six eight 265
pound former number one draft pick in
the NFL sure I don't that's who that was
and purple belt and jiu jitsu
I know I'm sorry it doesn't matter every
day right I know but the difference is
this boom right there right there yeah
it's a knife it goes right in there now
look look watch this now this sucks for
you because I'm gonna pull it out I'm
gonna go like this I'm gonna go You're
Gonna Lose barometric pressure in your
body got to get to a doctor like this
I'd hold it in you gotta hold it in it's
got to be this hold it in I go no no no
no no yes
no I go let me leave it in there
now I'm doing this I wiggle around like
a cherry like what's it called
um what's it called it's a it's a
joystick no you're jacking me up
joystick you jacking me up
now watch this watch this but here's the
thing you're not knife guy that's not
you bud you don't know it's fun in your
dreams but you don't know I was thinking
about that though you don't know nice or
I go like this yep the Achilles outside
oh God and then I run and you're like no
I go you ruined my Bella Jordan Fives
God a knife is a [__] nice I had this
special forces guy told me he goes think
about a knife he goes you get stabbed
like just like that if I do that to your
body if I go dupe like that you have to
get to a doctor
very quickly because the you I guess
something about losing pressure in your
body
losing blood too yeah but it's there's
something about the barometric or the
pressure so when you you there's a
there's a I guess there's a
equilibrium yeah
you will die yeah you will 100 die we
gotta stop the bleeding first of all
yeah stop the bleeding there it is
for headaches that's for a headache yeah
but your body
your body cannot deal with uh what's the
blood loss that screws you especially if
they hit some internal work it's not
even the blood loss though they say I
told you that bro knives usually produce
limited industry because they are
classified as low velocity Productions
medium philosophy
no one wants to stand by fatal traumatic
air embolism
following a stab wound yup traumatic
arabism positive pressure positive
pressure ventilation that's what I said
lung will cause rapid you die oh yeah
that's from 1993.
I know my friend of mine in college got
stabbed didn't even know it got stabbed
they got a big fight down in the
basement
adrenaline was probably through the room
feel it so he gets in the car with my
buddy and my buddy goes what the [__]
going on he goes and blood was pumping
out because so he got he hit his lung
and blood was going two students and he
goes dude I got stabbed
and my phone was like oh [__] he hit
your lung he knew enough because it was
like the blood somehow was kind of you
go like this pushing out let's go see
these chicks my friend my friend Bro
Science goes just push really hard on it
I guess that's what you're supposed to
and uh they drove to the hospital and he
was fine he died no he was totally fine
I mean you know he had to go under
surgery and all that but [__] he didn't
even know there's that myth too you got
you got to stop to bring your put
pressure on it so the blood didn't come
out and then also there's a myth too if
you get bit by a snake you gotta suck
the venom out that's not real that's not
real right it's not no it doesn't you're
supposed to have tourniquet around to
slow the blood flow not totally yeah I
don't know if the tourniquet's right but
there was a snake as we're talking
because some guy was like oh if I get
bit stuck out he goes absolutely don't
do that that does nothing you're wasting
your time yeah some people put ice on it
remove rings and watches before swelling
starts watch the bite with soap and
water cover the bite with clean dry
dressing Mark the Leading Edge of
tenderness swelling on the skin oh it
should just say do nothing well you know
but do nothing unless you get to a
hospital that has the Anthony it's like
the guy who got bit in the ass by the
water moxin and he went through
hallucination they couldn't get they
were stuck in the Everglades and they
couldn't get the boat going because it
was the weeds were so tangled up in the
propeller he had to sit there for 24
hours and go through every single you
can die usually but he went through
every single hallucination he was like
throwing up and almost died and he made
it through
ammonia was common remedy among
uh this is before Anti-Venom
nothing very painful but Commodities get
a knife and cut out as much of the wound
and hopefully the poison is possible
go to how long do you have with a
rattlesnake bite because I was thinking
by that I see the rattlesnakes on the
trailer I'm kind of nowhere near let me
see how do Native Americans deal with it
oh they just die it says
let me see go up go up no no please go
down I mean down this way yeah down how
did Native Americans survive oh oh there
it is avoid getting bit they use
shamanistic rituals rattlesnake bites
everything powder roots to leaves to
using their mouths to suck out the
poison which we know that doesn't work
yeah all right so here it goes uh widely
recommended until recently by physicians
for for removing Venom yeah because it
doesn't work yeah yeah you're there it's
a Viper and they have they have they
shoot the Venom into your body think
about one mile on the trails they would
have to bring the helicopter to get me
to the hospital to get the anti-venom
because if I get bit out there Daddy's
probably gonna die I saw a dog a pit
bull that had no use of its front right
left leg just didn't work I said what
happened he goes rattlesnake bit him
because they bite him on the nose no he
bit him on a leg leg died oh really just
died because it usually dogs you know
they go face first and they get those
juicy noses well all their like all like
when they bond the nose so juicy and
that spreads the Venom across their body
that's why I see people on the trails
I'm like there's rattlesnakes everywhere
why is your dog off the [__] leash
man like the chance of me in bed are so
high because Ralph snakes are everywhere
everywhere and they go for them my dog
got bit by a rattlesnake rattlesnakes
wave at me dude my dog got bit right on
the face my American Bulldog right on
the face didn't see the snake I just
heard him go oh or her go oh and then I
was like oh that's weird I'm telling you
it her face swelled up this big and she
she went I was like what's going on I
thought it was a bee sting she went she
was going like this walking and she just
went boom and fell right over
sucked up the nose I picked her up I
brought her to the vet
I was up in Malibu I brought her to the
vet on Third Street and I don't remember
what happened she was fine but I think
they said it's too late to add to to
administer anti-venom she we got to let
it just go through her system it was
something it's more of a dryer box also
super expensive the anti-venoms no punk
dude you know how they get the Venom
right they melt the snake
they take the snake they pop its fangs
into it and then they add you to it it's
just not that's actually not how they do
it bring it up here's how they do it
ready
again before you talk actually give it
to horses
okay that's not true listen they got a
tiny bit to horses and then what they do
is they extract that from the horse
because the horse produces antibodies I
don't think so chin go into how do they
get anti-venom not how much it is I mean
it says 40 to 70 grand which is crazy
right in my current stab like just let's
see how it goes through the night oh
yeah let's just let's wait a little bit
yeah yeah yeah I just have like a
payment plan I I got a 100 000 bill from
the vet recently 400. I have insurance
for the Corgi yeah kill them there you
go
yeah watch this remember immunizing
donor animals such as Horses that's what
I'm saying yeah
robust immune systems
of snake venom components enabling our
own immune defense to eliminate these
toxins yeah you shoot it up you shoot a
snake uh you shoot a sheep or but they
don't just hold a [__] stink and let
it bite the horse they take they milk it
and then they take that out and inject
in the horse that's what I'm saying okay
they get the Venom yes to create the
antibodies they [__] milk the snake
they jerk them they jerk the fangs both
fangs they jerk fangs they take they
they just milk it okay you ever seen
them bite it their fangs are deep Long
daddy they're huge
do you know how much you know how bad
that would hurt
you don't want to get bit by a gaboon
viper you know it's a myth too when they
say baby rattlesnakes can't control
their venom so they're more dangerous
fake news oh a fake what do you mean
it's not real what do you mean all my
son he watches all those shows on
natural juice but they they bite and
they they there's some guy on there who
has bro signs like we do he's like we
avoid the little ones right they're
they're Venom they don't know how to
control it and the experts like what'd
you say you realize he's not Google
training he's like what what are you
talking about because with the little
ones they bite they don't have to draw
all the venues absolutely not yeah
that's it y'all oh yeah so so forever
I've been told that uh maple syrup and
raw honey doesn't raise your blood sugar
because it's got its own immune system
or dude I've heard that so I've always
said that so I'm like you can eat as
much raw honey I say I call I call some
of my buddies who are they have their
phds I go hey does raw honey not raise
your blood sugar because this Bro
Science [__] that you hear everywhere is
such horseshit well my buddy you know
clap calls me and goes or he called Jay
I think he goes dude I know uh like me
and Clyde both love ice cream that's
like I love ice cream like from after so
I just love ice cream but I don't want
to eat it late because it raises your
blood you know uh sugar level and goes
dude turns out does it
I've been wearing that whoop band and it
shows you and I've been taking tests ice
cream doesn't raise your blood sugar
lips so you're good so like well say
less do a meat and [__] gallons of it
I talked to a doctor he's like are you
you stupid I was like yeah here's this
here's actually he's like who told you
I'm like my buddy's like is he a doctor
because of the fat in the ice cream it
actually it will it will be a slower
rise than say still straight sugar it's
so many calories you're so much sugar
you're gonna get fat bro and your blood
sugar is going to raise so much better
so you know you ever hear when they say
Vanguard and BlackRock own all like own
every company in the world that's you
that that is
there's a guy who's saying that with
authority and there's music behind it
goes black rock and and vanguard's own
on social media all the all the media
companies you know and it's like they
own everything and I sent that to some
of the people who make a lot of money in
the world and no BlackRock and Vanguard
you know people are just they're not
sent some people who are just in the
finance world and they were like do you
know how ignorant that is do you know
how they don't even know these people
don't even know what all right they go
these people don't even know what Black
Rock and Vanguard do they're not they
don't own their their index funds which
means you can go to them and say hey I
want to buy funds in this I want to buy
stock in this and then they have a
portfolio manager that does it they
don't own it they you own it but they
manage those [__] funds and and they
do they do all right they do it they
have good marketing they do all right
they don't own those companies that
shirt's too bad you know
yeah
so distracting hey crowd what do you
mean crowd does could you well there's a
large can they come with a vial of trt
if you're gonna sell that shirt dude
it's a me it's a large I'm a medium okay
I know I knew it's too big you know it's
too big you know like on the arms and
baggy right a little big a little big
you look like your your dog's legs you
know it looks like they're wrong well I
got I got Small Arms yeah Kermit arms
yeah Crowders like [__] but I'll never
be happy because wire sales down 20 on
this shirt this baseball team I was told
it looks good on me I don't mind it well
here's the thing that I that I would
like to have and it's a sin to ask for
anything when I have I'm such a lucky
person I would like to take longer than
me dude I'd like to have longer arms not
happening no no and longer legs not
happening and I'd like them to be a
little bigger and stronger I'd like to
have a little bit more of a Samoan Gene
in me somewhere I'd like to be a little
thicker unfortunately I am at the end of
the day a very I'm just not a very
strong guy and I have to come to terms
with that and it's okay I'm more my mom
than my dad at 56 though it's like time
to come to terms Bud time to come terms
dude how about this picture saying from
my boy Eric Williams who I just love met
with for two hours so talented how old
school two thousand what that's Nigel
Houston that was a you know a beast
super beast but uh I was so young I was
like why am I in a suit because I
remember I was working for UFC Fox I
just came off the fox lot straight
because we used to do the podcast on Fox
Sports so I came straight from there to
here because I was working that UFC show
I
Hernandez right there you do do you ever
do you ever and his brother look at your
hair dude how about that little tough
God you're a good looking man I was a
cute kid huh dude we've got a bad Bubba
not a bad profile dude we've aged like
fruit we were both a couple cuties both
I think that's why that is Aaron
Hernandez to a T-Rex yeah it is that's
Aaron Hernandez in court look at us look
at us look at your beard full we are
full oh great hope no gray we're full of
Hope and come aged like a couple of
[__] people we age like presidents
it's the best thing I've heard right
yeah
yep then did I send you the picture the
sassos in it too you guys any of that
one yeah
sasso's taking a selfie yeah we're gonna
get Sasso back on I know I haven't he's
those were the days those were the Fox
Sports days dude we didn't even have
video Back Then
so nuts we did look at that dude look at
that backdrop you got a box and burn
shirt on I got a g-star watch on a
G-Shock yep yep yeah you do yeah you do
yeah oh there it is
and look at just the general background
because they just gave us a set that was
an office space so the back has like I
remember that that's like well you were
still fighting yeah has McNabb in it and
like some random [__] remember our first
live show was oh look at Special K in
the comments every time we'd go I would
say this to you as we leave I go train
hard and you go yes sir yep every time
and I meant it hell yeah you did I
really did I'd get dead serious
train hard someone says why don't you
have will on anymore well you don't talk
to us
we love him he's just no he does talk I
talk to him he's like married now I
texted him he's just like he's hard yeah
he's doing his thing he's he's his own
podcast his own life man yeah I miss him
yeah we just get older and you stop
hanging out as a crew when you got kids
and you got you know that's my thing
like you know Eric was with us and uh
I'll send you another picture but
back to Eric Williams Eric um
he's been with me he was the first guy I
was like man you you have something
special you and I was just one of his
first guys he's like we need to Market
you outside just the fighting world like
let me document all this I'm like all
right whatever and this is before
anybody's doing it so so Eric was with
me when I was in Denver he was in The
Green Room with me you know for some of
my big fights some of that the pictures
you and you and GSP yeah I'm gonna send
you the GSP one I'm gonna post this one
he can Eric Williams is a crazy good
photographer he's going to release all
he's going to release all he has this
big release coming soon his pictures he
takes pictures of too he's like I
Googled Eric Williams photography so
hopefully this is that's him okay that's
him ewillphoto.com he's you will on
there too his pictures are Rhonda that
no one's seen are good look at how good
he is
I just sent you the one of me and Jesus
you guys are great with Rhonda I don't
like he's I'm on his main page that's
fine um okay we're still scrolling I
know but I didn't make it why because
Batista is about the coolest looking
human being
especially when he's younger Nick Cage
yeah he's he's such a big deal
all right let's check out the GSP one
look at the size of me GSP looks your
size it's so weird
his calves were huge yeah but so were
his thighs his thighs he was big all
over and he he was like his broad
shoulder skinny way he felt like a
chance right like a chimp just uh the
nicest guy ever how's this how's he's
got an apple bottom yeah oh yeah got a
real ass on him yeah the nicest guy ever
but we were there and Brilliant such a
smart guy loves history loves War Art of
War is his favorite book at the time I
remember but I like when I forget about
this stuff like we're always caught up
in our world I forget about all this old
school stuff so he sends my picture like
holy [__] dude this is so old school
because I'd spend weeks with just me and
GSB training really I moved would you
ever you wouldn't roll with him oh yeah
no we'd roll Spar really yeah man he's
so much smaller he's so skilled though
and strong like he helped me out so much
I went to Montreal he gave me his
blueprint of how to run my Camp I'd go
to restaurants with him you want to and
this is Peak GSP before he fought Jake
Shields I fly to Montreal God stay with
them it was nuts
yeah true professional
and what was his mind what was his mind
said before he fought was it what was he
terrified he was terrified terrified he
really he just he didn't want to do so
nervous
I remember the first time I met him I I
came off The Ultimate Fighter house
right after beating Marcus Jones like
that I beat him to go to the finals
you're in the house for six months six
weeks I finally get out to the real
world it's UFC I forget what maybe UFC
100 whenever he fought Thiago Alves
and so I was close with Greg Jackson and
Greg Jackson is when you get out come to
the Mandalay Hotel like all right so I
go there my nose is broke and I I go up
there your nose was broke from that
fight yeah Marcus Jones need me in the
nose and broke my awful
so I go the hotel room he goes hey GSP
is in the suite I gotta run down and get
some food for him can you go up there
and just give him company he he's
fighting tomorrow he gets hates being
alone I'm like I don't know dude like
George Saint Pierre I'm like at the time
I've never met him like I don't [__]
know the guy he's like just go up there
keep him company like like history I
don't even know history you got a broken
nose yeah I look like [__] so I go up
there and I'm like George what's up dude
and he's like I'm so [__] scared
Brendan I'm so [__] scared I'm like
what and I'm like this is gsp's like I'm
so [__] what the [__] am I doing what
am I doing I'm so [__] scared I'm
like I don't know how to help you out
here now I'm scared like what are we
doing remember do you remember what Greg
Jackson said to GSP in that fight with
Thiago Alves well he's like I tore my
groins and hit it hit him with your
groin oh okay
give me I need five five minutes of hell
son God those days man it's just
monsters like and when Eric's showing me
those pictures he has a picture of me
and Jon Jones it's a Young Jon Jones
like John before all the crazy [__] yeah
man John's just jacked he's standing did
you ever spar with John oh yeah you did
yeah so when you say Spar like what you
guys would wrap it up and just kind of
move around like no no no I wouldn't go
crazy we go crazy oh you would yeah
they know it like because I've seen a
lot of like snow went light back then
really no but you see that a lot now but
now it's now it's a different timeline
so back then you guys just got in there
and banged like we're fighting for our
lives but but you're too big to be going
that hard with some guys right that
means it's too small so you had to have
been GSP no I couldn't hit gspsu
talented they don't give a [__] man God
damn it's not like that like we go full
go what GSP dip Dodge and he's fighting
at 230 pounds 235 pound guy like yeah me
Shane like just people hit too hard he
doesn't get hit man that's what he's too
good
and John will just mopped the floor with
everybody no matter how hard you went oh
my God it was so good still is
some old school [__] and then you would
you have days where it was just
wrestling just Jiu Jitsu like yeah just
striking yep oh yeah
not sure too big huh come on man like
keep going back come on I'm trying I'm
trying to keep my eyes open dude I gotta
get myself into a sense of flow I need
some calm energy is there steroids in
that this is my magic mind bro oh
I do you know what that's why you're
prickly you haven't had your magic mine
I love it
I love the way it tastes the problem is
it like lasts all day but the problem is
if I don't do it I notice it now well me
too dude I drink a half a cup of coffee
in the mornings and I down a magic mine
well it makes I guess I'll take a second
one make sure can I take a second one
bro
I turn come on now
it's like a Five Hour Energy Shot yeah
oh we're going 10 hours
don't overdo this [__] I did down four
of them on Monday you can't do that I
don't you worry Don't Be extreme dude
one is good but here's maybe two dude
but you got a space here I had four
podcasts on Monday you ever done four
Brian too much I would need after two I
need two you're just not yourself yeah
now thank God at shop show and big fight
week with UFC 291 so I can ride with
that then I find the kid right you can
carry that we can move back you know
back and forth I can do that then I'd
the third show was one-on-one with Luke
Thomas that drops Thursday Luke knows
fighting better than anybody so he can
carry that and then Bradley Martin who's
on fight campaign was like hey man my
guest dropped out I need to do the
podcast I'm like cool can you do like
Tuesday or Wednesday he's like no it has
to be today I'm like I have three shows
he goes please bro I need you otherwise
I'm not doing campaign I'm like I'll see
you at 2 30. that's when you need your
magic mind Bradley's in the news right
now because
he people don't realize they take him so
serious but when he had Nate diazon he
was like who do you think would win a
street fight between me and you oh Renee
Diaz well and Nate was great about he
starts laughing us [__] kill you he's
gonna kill you what are you talking
about and Bradley's laughing he had
Devin Haney on the small boxers he goes
who'd win in a street fight
now that one
that one Bradley has more of a chance
because he's like I'm not talking about
boxing I'm not gonna sit back and box
him I'm 200 whatever 40 pounds shredded
260. she's huge so and athletic and
athletic and explosive yeah he's like no
no because I was making fun of him I
started the podcast I'm like yeah stop
with this [__] dude you get destroyed
he's like Devin Haney's tiny I go dude
he would light you up so I told him a
story about me fighting this 145 pounder
box when I was ranked top 10 in the
world the guy destroyed me I go and I
was you said to your trainer I think I'm
gonna get knocked out in the world he
was catching you in like UFC Executives
I'm like what are you doing I want out
was he catching he's the worst oh
people don't realize what boxers like so
I told Bradley I'm telling you he's
gonna [__] you because dude I'm not
gonna box him I'll just smother him yeah
and I go oh you'd like do what the
mountain did in Game of Thrones I get on
top and like crutches faces yeah yeah
you'd be definitely yeah I go but you
got to stop this he's not with he and
Bradley is saying Bradley's competitor
so Bradley and his mind actually thinks
he could
I said I said you don't get to where
you're at not having self belief I go
you're wrong but he needs to he needs to
you're wrong you need to get humble he
needs to roll with someone like Nate to
see what happens it would just it he
doesn't understand but he's not talking
about that he was not he was in an
archeon and ring that [__] me up how
about Street Fighter like you're having
tables and [__] like boot stomping he
was yeah cars and [__] like I can pick
him up slime on the car you're gonna get
tired and I told him Nate would [__] him
up but I said I'll tell you right now
like the small guys you don't understand
you just you wouldn't have time to react
and they can control your body movement
like you're not gonna be able to pick
him up you don't think everyone tries to
pick those guys up when they're first
starting out they get so good at
controlling your posture you're gonna be
[__] that you hold your ankle or
something like that I go like Mighty
Master [__] you up he fights 125 pounds
he would [__] you up street fight brain
pull Mighty Mouse [__] you up heels I
don't know who my mouse is I went well
that's a problem just to start I go he's
the best
125 of all time he would [__] you up he
probably was probably 150 walking around
one maybe one now 140. very short very
short but I've seen him so skilled so
skilled well the maybe pound the best
ever yeah there's argument for that yeah
I just told him he goes that's fine I'm
not talking about that he knows I'm I'm
talking like Devin hey but then how
would Mighty Mouse beat somebody that
big though his back choke him out get
his back like this get his back and he
could ankle lock um Bradley he's like no
I could pull him up he would break your
ankle like you before he even knew it
was happening yeah he's good at
everything anyone see it coming you
wouldn't touch him people I can get hold
of him his distance whether it's a car
pool remember when I was boxing and we
were with uh TJ De La Shaw and I and I
you know I just couldn't help but I go
he's just a lot smaller than me and I
didn't even get that out and you go how
do you want to lose how do you want to
lose tell me how you want to lose it oh
my God I'm like no no you're right
you're right you're right
but I think most people Ellen needs
Magic Mike if you've never rolled so I
was rolling with my buddy uh Tino and
he's he's a black belt not a competitor
a guy like built like me maybe maybe
actually a little skinnier
and you now that you know this
he was catching me with a DARS choke
from every angle and I couldn't figure
out what the [__] he was doing I just
couldn't figure it out no matter what I
did I'd get caught or should you right
and and that's what people don't realize
I think if they haven't rolled they
don't realize that there's just you you
can't cover all the bases Brad yeah
Bradley's not gonna talk about and then
Brad then Logan Paul went on his podcast
and gave a message to Bradley because
Bradley was on Nate Diaz and he goes I
like Jake and Logan I really like Jake I
respect what he's doing he goes I want
to see Nate knock him out because I want
Jake to become a meme well his older
brother Logan heard that I was like what
the [__] you doing Bros for clicks like
you're our friend what are you doing man
he's like why would you want my brother
to lose and be a meme like that's [__]
up he's like so you need to be humbled
which he might be right he's like he
needs to be humbled so he goes Bradley I
will fly you out to Costa Rica or Puerto
Rico where the [__] they live and you'll
spar with me
yeah I seen it because I seen it and I
go are you gonna do it he goes no I
don't want to box him I'm just trying to
straight up fight he was a box I mean I
get destroyed he was fight though I have
a chance
all right Doug
um
Logan Logan is rolling Brogan Logan's a
big kid and athletic not as big as
Bradley no but Logan straight boxing
yeah Bradley it's not a boxer Bradley's
talking about just like
close the door and see how it goes
I mean what are we talking about are we
talking about biting and gouging uh
we're talking about survival Daddy yeah
I mean I don't like this conversations
because then now we're talking about
are there weapons involved yeah I think
can you curb you it doesn't work it is
like I don't care about that okay I mean
I guess if life and death struggle what
are we talking about biting and tearing
each other's eyes out and I guess I I
that's not what we're talking about the
Bradley goes How would how would it Go
me versus you come on
yeah but that he goes he goes part of me
like obviously I know dude I'm trolling
but it's funny how your audience like
the fight I didn't get so upset I'm like
okay because the lack of respect is just
because you're a big guy freaky ass
freaky very freaky and also has that
fire in him where if he focus on it like
Bradley's a beast dude if he focused on
him if he took Jiu Jitsu you know one
year of Jiu Jitsu you're everyone's
having a problem everyone you know when
you're a lot more than a year but yeah
yeah but don't say everyone but the
common person would no I'm just like the
black belt I think a black belt I think
a black belt no no no but but I take way
longer in the year way longer I don't
know Bob no when when you're that strong
with Jujitsu it can it can kind of like
doesn't neutralize a lot of [__] no no
not at a high level
we've had big guys come in so so we've
been around so he trains he trains for a
year
and then he rolls with Dylan danis after
that gets tapped down 30 seconds less
even after a year yeah it doesn't matter
there's not enough hours in the day to
make up for it even when you're that's
that much stronger in there has nothing
to do with those guys that leverage they
know the openings there's not enough
hours a day to cover it it's just not
that's that's all those guys do
you know it's just it's just it is what
it is just takes a lot of time yeah and
that's all those guys do for years
you're just size doesn't matter it's all
they do yeah they tap you out like that
that's what makes it so special
otherwise everybody could do it right
they can't
yeah well
he likes to troll
that's what he said he goes he gets
clicks and people get so upset he goes I
think it's funny I was like I keep doing
his thing man but I've been playing with
this question because he's a beast
you know it's not like me asking it's
like it's like that guy's that guy is
crazy strong deadlifts what seven and
change sure can dunk a basketball do all
kinds of crazy [__] sometimes that stuff
doesn't matter though but I hear you no
it doesn't like when you guys rolled you
reversed them yeah
what's funny is that I didn't reverse
him but I could have reversed you you
put him in the air I could have done but
I was like I'm not gonna do this this
spider guard yeah it's just not his
language I'm not gonna get on top now
we're really going he's a good guy
though he's just he's a Bradley's great
he's funny
um well that's what I was trying to tell
them I go they're just you're going to
make mistakes
and out and it's everything yeah like
that that thing where he was riding high
on me and I and I just kind of went I
just it was an old school sweep yeah and
if I wanted if I really sweeped I just
scissors my body over I would you know
and I'm an old man so think about what
what Dylan Dennis would do because we
started talking about that where I was
like you know but he and he always says
that he's like no I'm not talking about
jujuice I'm talking like in in the
streets of New York if [__] went down I
even still as a kid those guys just
they're bursting it's not like they
don't know how to do that like a good
boxer understands distance like you're
gonna come at him and do one straight
box you have about a chance straight
boxes yeah but you're gonna get punched
really quickly in the face you're gonna
get caught you are going to get caught
it's gonna go like this boom boom boom
and you can avoid it like with a blast
double leg where he randomly gets a car
and then pick them up and slam him he's
so big like you know it's okay with a
boxer though
that's why Devin Haney I'm like yeah he
probably beat him in the street fight
yeah so straight boxing yeah
yeah just again do with the mountain
just take your [__] stupid thumbs and
push their eyes yes I'd love to do that
to you dude yes who you I just take my
[__] you know how easy it'd be it'd
be like a warm Peach I know dummy but
then yes why do you always go for my
weiner dude because that's where I go
Jack you go to the wiener yeah
no I'm turning it you can't stop that
isn't that crazy if it was a knife yeah
you're not knife guy that's the other
problem and you don't know that man I'm
gonna start being Knife Guy oh if that
shirt was a medium I would believe some
of it it's distracting because it's a
large and it just stop acting you bro
it's baggy and you have a wife oh hell
yeah dude got real American History
action [__] how am I [__] 56 with
this physique honestly dude and where is
the hair under my arms why does it look
like I have no hair under my arms do you
ever yeah I shaved I can't see my chest
why because my wife I was like trimming
it my wife goes just shave it down let
it grow back and I was like all right
no now I'm [__]
your wife's like can you just shave it
down and like just paint your skin back
hey that's a low blow bro that's where I
draw the line can you just go like can
you do blackface and like like dye your
skin listen dude look just because my
wife might have dated a couple of black
professional athletes does not mean and
I'm fine with it I'm totally fine with
it as you can tell by my voice
[__] secure with myself
dude dude you jacked dude dude what the
[__] is going on
ah [__] dude oh man can you put the
shirt back on I see you it looks like a
Russian wrestler oh your stupid belt
dude oh my God I bought
bro come on man it's waterproof
all belts are waterproof um
be cool man
get it man what what'd you get it I got
it at a [__] mouth store and I had to
buy it yeah I was in Greenville North
Carolina get it I want to know that's a
20 belt I'm gonna buy one of those
because it doesn't go off when I walk
through the airport because I'm
traveling not metal there no I mean it
is but it's not enough I prefer those
belts that you there's no holes yeah I
think it's an aluminum so I pop it yeah
I like that and it just kind of Blends
in with a tapered waist the belt bumps
me out
dude shut up man
I want it I want to jump on you right
now but and I want to do the mountain
thing crush your face in like a badass
you really couldn't do that to me you
act like I don't have any skills it
wouldn't matter just do it no you
couldn't I would [__] thing is we
can't try because you go blind
you're not going to do that to me you
can't do it all right
you you'd have to use Jiu Jitsu to kill
me you're not going to do this [__]
you're not going to squeeze my throat
it's never going to happen well I do
Jitsu and then just getting full amount
and then just take my full amounts not
this is not the end of the world for me
honestly honestly it's not the end of
the world for me I can get out of full
map
dude did you see
um Aaron Hernandez brother could there
be a worse family I was about to say
whether the worst family all the time
now he was planning a school shooting
but what did I put my shirt back on yeah
that belt is worse than your shirt my my
skin is a little white
um now are those the white chocolate
macadams why don't you give me more
friends that house I don't want to
chewing on the mic but um there's
nothing like Macadamia sometimes you
gotta take a little break and just
somebody came to my house with some
chocolate covered macadamia nuts get
them out of here get them out they're
good for you dude I know but the
macadamia nuts from House of macadamia
there they got the sugar-free Oh I
thought you said they came enough
chocolate I don't know how they get them
like this you're talking about the best
nuts on the planet dude I was on uh I
was talking a little birdie who works at
House of smack damias you know they're
coming out with a uh Macadamia milk
well now listen put down your coffee I
was gonna say know this I will put that
in my coffee every morning
every morning the problem is not for
just the rich they work with Farms Farm
owned 90 Farmers you see how these are
they're not too sweet
but somehow I think it's a sugar-free
chocolate no sugar added and and yet
they they taste sweet and salty at the
same time
and buttery oh they're nice dude it's
ridiculous one of a kind I call it a
steak not just for the rich anymore try
your steak using the the all the
macadamia nuts I said olive oil right
try your steak using the macadamia nuts
are we selling olives right now
there is a true buttery flavor it has a
high smoke point which means you can you
can heat it up
and it just makes the steak delicious
they are good I like the the Macadamia
the 45 Magnum nut bars the variety pack
here's what we're gonna do for you guys
we're gonna get a special fire kid Army
for limit time you're getting a free box
of 45 Macadamia snack bars one of each
flavor when you visit
houseomeacademias.com tfak plus you get
20 off your entire order with that code
tfak your 20 off the the chocolate
covered vanilla regular
the white chocolate I love those white
chocolate
yeah but these might be my new favorites
they're delicious this might be my new
favorite houseomeacademias.com tfaq get
20 for your entire order plus a free box
of 45 McDermott snack bars one of each
flavor okay so well chocolate chip
cookie dough well
tell you something Buddy
nootropics
about some of your brain Alpha Brain I
could use it you want something for your
sleep new mood you want something for
your digestion toad Alpha Prince not
just the stuff you see at Whole Foods or
Walmart just your traditional Alpha
Brain they got Alpha Brain instant Alpha
Brain Black Label Alpha Brain Focus shot
Alpha Brain pre-workout Alpha Brain all
over dude it's the flagship of on it you
want the best supplements on planet
Earth obviously they got pre-workout for
you they got post workout they got
Warrior bars protein powders creatine
streaming Fitness they got got it all on
it.com slash f-a-t-k you save temps off
the entire site you're welcome audit.com
f-a-t-k now now yeah so Aaron Hernandez
brother arrested for allergy playing
school shootings and his plan was to
shoot up ESPN because they live in
Bristol right and ESPN headquarters at
Bristol so you want to shoot up ESPN2
but on social media he made several
threats
like like a lot of threats they took
them down but they made several threats
that's why they finally went to him
so in July several individuals reported
that uh BPD the DJ that DJ that's his
name had acted erratically and set
alarming text matches one mentioned
plans involving Taking Lives if certain
conditions weren't met
um
DJ's ex revealed that he skipped his
court date and went to the brown to
brownie University and UConn where he
played football at reportedly entering
class he played football there reporting
entering classrooms in buildings
um not well
planning campus school shootings they
put will I kill absolutely I've warned
my enemy so pay up front everyone's like
what are you talking about
uh he warned them that he was on foot
armed and if we approached him he will
kill us all okay ABN yelling shoot me
now I think they come from they tased
them I think they come from uh uh family
abuse their dad was abusive
so I think if you mix in the dark
history of your childhood being abused
then probably maybe a splash of CT and
just being bad people
he had the perfect storm there yeah this
is awful that families yeah he worked at
one school after he uh finished school I
think he worked at Brown either brown or
Connecticut and he played at one of the
schools he played it but he's going for
those two schools like they owe him
something they played at UConn they
didn't see any ESPN knows them if they
don't give him the royalties from his
brother it's just he's just acting
erratic and he saw he said the girl his
girl his ex he's like he doesn't want to
shoot but she is she's in the way she'll
get shot too oh so here's one of his
texts says chilling tax uh uh Yukon
program is going to pay unless I have a
package deal they make sense and I get
my estate and every single thing I've
worked for they're like what are you
talking about the coaching University
officials want to be selfish and select
about [__] well I am too very they are
going to get surprised you can do love
you I would recommend remain away from
there because when I go out I'm taking
down everything I don't give a [__] who
gets caught in the crossfire I've died
for years now and now it's other
people's turn that makes sense I'm
prepared to give my life so I if I don't
need to see you I'm the outside no I
love you not all shootings are bad I'm
realizing terrible uh some are necessary
for change to happen
he's uh he's obviously schizophrenic
you know
schizophrenia uh affects men in their
20s and 30s mostly so we're good yeah
we are but that that's a very that's a
that's a that's a rambling of a paranoid
schizophrenic unfortunately
so because it doesn't make sense because
we sat down you're like when you say
package deal what what are you referring
you think they oh he's not he's not he's
not his right mind our our
um did they came from a very troubled
childhood the dad abused them yeah I
suppose that I was really strict the dad
was Jack too and a star football player
he was
and he was he was just abusive huh I
guess bring it up to have you watched
the documentaries lifetimes like will
you play your internet is in this I'm
like no no no no no no no I'm not the
guy you know they said something to the
effect I'll just do the gay scenes I've
heard something beaten beaten and it's
actually abused as a child that's Aaron
Hernandez which most likely is too
often beaten by his father
oh I had a sexual religion High School
quarterback
oh man and then also you know bisexual
use Melissa as a kid it says well so so
um this is something I I've talked about
before but
sometimes when you say bisexual like
when you're abused as a child by a man
or an older boy
you can be a straight boy but when you
are at a very delicate part of your
sexual development and your
psychological development something can
happen where you get abused okay and it
it feels you don't know what's happening
and it actually feels good
like the feeling of it and they say that
those boys mouth the mouth those boys
grow up to be men and they're straight
they have a wife and sometimes they
deviate and they go and find some male
Chopper or whatever yeah childhood to
kind of relive that and that's what they
that's what that's what might have been
going on with him where his his wires
got you know confused and crossed and
either way that's what happens when
children are abused they say a lot of
women that put on a lot of weight they
were sexually abused
I'm afraid that sexual abuse of children
and developing teens is so much more
rampant than we can even imagine
you know and I was thinking about this
too like
you know sometimes when you're
successful in life you you should be
grateful and and feel lucky because you
didn't choose your genetics you didn't
choose your parents and you didn't
choose not to have that trauma that was
just luck of the draw yeah and there are
people that get destroyed man and there
are also people that go through it and
they come through it but it you know if
you're not talking that's why like with
my kids I know I'm strict and they'll
probably be mad
but I'll tell my girl about this I'm not
trying to make light of whether it's
humor and everything but my son wanted
to have a play date with his buddy who's
on the baseball team he's like Dad can I
go over there I go no
his dad I'm telling we're gonna have a
pool either gonna have a pool party
they'd live a mile away come and go I go
no I don't know the parents yes but I we
know you know the mom like I don't know
if there's an uncle there if and I don't
know that Mom well enough to have you
and her be in charge of you swimming
you're okay I just I don't play that
[__] bud it's just not happening Pros
con they can come here that's why she
always go you can invite him here and
the parents come over here because then
it's on my watch I'm on it but I don't
know them they're probably I don't know
if they're on it like I am yep I'd say
because something happens to you dude
you're changed forever yep that Uncle
who I don't know touches your wiener
like you're screwed for Life Dog then
it's on me I said you might be mad now
when you're 21 I'm lucky and go but did
you get molested
dad was doing it right dude bro I'm
telling you man but did you get molested
you have fun did you have fun yeah did
you get molested no what's up daddy yep
yep I don't do play dates no sleepovers
never no until you're 18. that's where
that [__] happens
yeah it's always some weird uncle or
some [__] at the house crashing on the
couch
you know one of the things that's so
important for any kind of trauma is is
laughter and I'll be at the Ontario
Improv this Friday Saturday yeah and if
you you know and if 10 off when you got
arrested well if you've got I'm trying
to get back here I'm saying comedy can
really take your mind off things yeah
ten percent off I never said 10 off but
yeah well I'm just spitballing ideas
okay I understand I'll be at the Ontario
but you got to prove it Saturday got to
prove it see how seamlessly I work that
in I like it dude yeah
I'm not doing any of that [__] but
Friday at the ice out it's almost sold
out if you got molested come I guess but
either way you're not there shopping
friends we have 20 tickets left me and
my buddies and then uh Phoenix Arizona
two shows one magical night dude August
11th stand up live I'm in Omaha Nebraska
eating all your barbecue and farting
Kansas City Patrick Mahomes is open up
for me August 17th yes I'm in Ohio uh uh
Liberty Township and then Columbus Ohio
oh by the way also Covina Covina
September 8 and 9.
now uh August August three to five I'm
at cap cities in Austin and Joe Rogan is
going to open for me
nice
that's the rumor who set me up for
failure dude all right because I'm gonna
come out in the bike where the [__]
Rogan yeah we too busy too busy they
sent me
shave your head get them out there uh
it's gonna be fun let's go I got
molested be cool yeah be cool dude
by the same guy actually and then I got
uh but I went and told my mom it wasn't
to be honest with you
uh it was I couldn't figure out what the
[__] was going on and I was like
probably nine or ten and I was like what
this doesn't make sense why is I woke up
and his hands without my pants and then
my friend died my friend Donnie said he
sucked his dick and I went what
no I don't want to tell anybody I'm
telling my mom and I went right to my
mom my mom told the camp director then
nothing happened to me uh he got he got
moved this was in
1980 or 79 or 78 by the 70s 1978
probably I think yeah it's probably 78
70 might have been 77 and uh I remember
my mom told me that the his wife who was
the arts and craft teacher said oh God
she they said hey he's been doing this
and she goes oh God he's up to that
stuff again that's what she said that
was the 70s dude you guys were wild yes
and then they just got sent on their
merry away
you know hey uh question
um three times though so you told your
mom after the third time or the first
time I would go we would go on camping
trips so the camp Council would take a
bunch of boys to Camp trips and this is
what I remember see how we held were you
I don't know like probably 11. see my
kid's not going on that 10 11 12. uh
younger than 12. and I remember my buddy
John was a muscular kid
we were naked we had been skinny dipping
and he he went like this to us we were
standing there and he goes and there's a
bone and he was telling us about
something and he goes there's a bone
right here and he reached under my
friend John right in front of us no and
and touched his taint with his finger
there's a bone right under here I mean
and we all went that was weird that he
touched you there and that was when we
started thinking and then I said I woke
up and I think he was touching my wiener
you got a handful yeah and so he was
clearly he was one of those pedophiles
though that was like he couldn't catch a
ball I remember I threw a ball at him he
went like that he was built like a pair
and he was really sweet he wasn't like a
he wasn't like one of those horrible
Predators who you know like those those
sadistic he was more like this he was
like that man boy love or something he
was like
he was like a still a predator yeah but
he's a pedophile yeah so I I I don't
really have much I don't have my feeling
about pedophiles you wouldn't want me in
charge because they wouldn't be around
anymore yeah but he was um says
everybody yeah he was one of those guys
who was like
you know he was in love
like a like one of those gentle
pedophiles it sounds like a real victim
right now though I wasn't I went right
to my mom I was like after the third
time though that's my problem dude you
almost did three times the third time
three times until I was like this
doesn't make I was like you wake up
you're like wait a minute what the [__]
is going on here I remember that
because what I started doing was I
started waiting before I forget I
started avoiding going on the camping
trips we would go on canoe trips
it'd be an overnight thing you'd go on
Lake winnipes never happen until my
son's 18.
well when your son's 14 he can do it nah
yeah maybe he's like six foot he'll be
fine 14 is gonna be tough kids I'm gonna
scare the [__] out now now Britain I
don't know if you know this but the
upper classes of Britain used to send
their children away to boarding school
as young as six as young as six no just
bad parenting I mean he's trying to get
rid of the upper class now what happens
in those boarding schools was that
everybody the upperclassmen molest the
younger classmen the teachers the clergy
everybody was [__] the boys Jesus so
the the sexual abuse of of the Upper
Crust of England was very real very
rampant and by the way and they just
don't talk about to this day and they
just don't talk about it
they don't talk about it and also um I I
would have you know I have been in
situations with Blue Bloods when they
get drunk you start Blue Bloods are like
the aristocrats and when they get drunk
one of the guys where are they're
getting drunk one of the guys
like I was here on a couch with my buddy
and he he kind of surfed over me and
rubbed his body and his dick kind of hit
my shoulder and I was like that's weird
I don't know that guy how old were you
grabbed ah 50.
48. well that's just him hitting on you
bro and my buddy goes oh typical upper
class Brits they get gay when they get
drunk oh my God what do you mean it's a
little too cool about that they they
when they go away to boarding school
they've all been you know indoctrinated
sorry if I'm speaking out of turn
Britain but I think you guys know what
I'm talking about
yeah that's a that's an Unwritten
that'll come out mark my words that'll
come out
see if it already has come out look at
well you're looking for that chin let me
take a picture look up eating Academy
last week
I'm not making light of molestation for
sure in the UK and you said what about
it
I just want to see if there's been any
uh former eating teacher jills for
sexuality
there's a bunch of Articles there's
another one under it oh no yeah there's
always that stuff but it but it happens
rather than with the teachers it
probably happens a lot with uh
pedophile eating rape culture yeah
there you go
yeah there's a lot of it there's a lot
of that stuff the boys because they
would be separated by sex you know and
it was the boys that was the
Aristocrat unveils the extent of sexual
abuse had eaten there you go see has
helped to shed light on the extent of
rape and sexual abuse in the exclusive
Public School Eaton uh and when they say
public but in Europe that means a
private school I believe Robert Montague
the son of the 10th Earl of Sandwich
described how he stopped the young boy
at the school from committing suicide
after he was raped by two prefects in
fact he was so concerned for the young
victim that he kept in touch with him
all night via walkie-talkie
unfortunately these types of incidents
are nothing new at Elite Public Schools
such as eating according to Mr Montague
yeah
yeah I don't want to say that word but
yeah yeah young boys act as slaves to
the older ones
what is that with that weird like older
to younger like like you hear it in like
football teams wrestling teams there's
like uh hazing that gets accused of
sexual assault and stuff like
I'm sorry what does that mindset come
from of like like that hazing my my
feeling and my guess is it's probably
men who are older who already have
sexual attraction for boys and I also
think anytime you have a group of men in
in when it's a large group of men
typically the most aggressive
asocial and violent takeover
so if you meet anyone who speaks the
queen's English that probably had some
experience at 50 too bro yeah yeah hey
at that point he did nothing to fight it
I did not I did not do anything well I
was rather taken aback sound like Terry
Crews right now when his when his uh
rather well-coofed pants brushed against
my chin anyone ever tried to rub their
old cockatiel on your face no but I
think I told this before the storyboard
there's a guy who was working at a
church oh yeah and he would me and my
friends a skateboard he would always
asked us to come over and talk to us
about God she took us to his backyard
and did a
that was the closest thing but nothing
didn't touch you no he felt weird though
my parents didn't use a smoker ah maybe
he just kind of sounds like a good time
well I mean when you want to baptize a
bunch of prepubescence it's gonna save
you from going slip and slide no this
guy sounds a good time living with his
mom my friend was watching you he takes
those dip things and he watched you put
five in your mouth yeah and he goes how
is he alive [__] what's your friend's
name
Mark well Mark I'm not [__] right and I
didn't get molested but that's a lot
that's whatever dude uh kg ever anyone
ever try to rub your cocktail my mom was
very much like you especially after my
brother passed he didn't let me like
leave the house yeah my kids can be as
bad as they want but when they're
turning around look at him go but did
you get molested
it could be a shirt did you give him a
lasted what's up Daddy I mean your
vigilance is is not lost on it dude yeah
they can't go you know the number one
rule no sleepovers unless it's over here
no exceptions yeah
yeah I would uh and no Story Time with
Uncle Brian
you have some sympathy for these
molesters he was a nice guy man you
you're not you're not very
confrontational if I was your teacher
no teacher ever hit on me also my
teachers were warlocks they didn't have
a chance yeah they're kicking out well I
always had a fantasy a couple teachers
of mine I never had any good looking
teachers real shame man this guy Mr
McGee you just found out you're gay yeah
oh man I'll have you myself Mr Davis man
oh I said Jack there's this girl I knew
who loved hairy men my friend had was
very hairy and she goes oh my God it's
the legs I go you like that so weird she
goes yes and I go watch she goes I just
love a big giant guy with a hair all
over his body I said why she goes I
think it's because when I was a student
I was like you know and I had a teacher
who was like he had he had these wrists
and this big watches and he was just
really hairy and he smelled so good and
I thought he was like just so hot and it
was like when I was becoming sexual I
was like I can't [__] hear this [__]
this stuff happens oh God you start to
try to grow out your hair she goes do
you like a guy you can't see a skin she
goes yes I just like a [__] cave but
Armenia girl man
well remember remember orlowsky when he
first got in the UFC he had hair on his
shoulder oh yeah he's got hair on his
shoulders yeah guys guys when he first
came on the scene oh he's like a
werewolf werewolf he shaved that [__]
though once he got more famous yeah all
right what do you got Jen all right well
quick question for Brian now this
episode can get flagged all the time
we'll see man but uh right do you
normally when your kid take uh skinny
dipping because I don't think I've ever
swam naked as a kid with friends well
this was in the 70s no that's what I'm
saying like was it normal back yeah yeah
just asking Junior gay friends they're
too young to be yeah there was no but
when you went to Camp I went to summer
camp my parents were overseas so I had
to go to summer camp
I didn't see my parents yeah that sucks
and um I went to boarding school and
then I would go to uh summer camp
but before that I would go to summer
camp too because we'd come to the states
and it was either stay at my
grandparents but whose idea was it the
skinny dip all the time was that you
buddy
um no when you were on a camping trip or
whatever everybody would just take their
clothes off and not have shorts
you did though cause you're on a camping
trip yes we did but we just got naked
that's the problem because we weren't
showering we probably jumped in the lake
and we just saw pedophiles call that you
chum in the water yeah but none of us
thought about it really that's the
problem looking back though there was a
kid who was really gay and and we
thought he was just super sensitive and
we used to like make fun of him but not
in a bad way like he cried he cried
because his parents weren't coming the
day he thought they were we were like
this poor kid we were like you're we
didn't know though we just thought he
was too being too sensitive and he
missed his mom and dad you piece of [__]
we were like don't be a [__] he was
super feminine yeah yeah and then you
guys no he wouldn't want him he wouldn't
jump in the water naked yeah because
he's a good guy
and he has a Skinny Dip but if you're
the one you were asking for it if you
were with a bunch of us guys we're boys
and we're all naked and you're like I
don't want to we would have roasted you
for sure
you're like can you believe that guy
grabbed my junk yeah dude because you're
constantly rubbing in his face jumping
into the well you got a bunch of boys
naked and that's a pedophile's dream we
didn't know but of course he's a
pedophile that's why he was a camp
counselor what may why would you spend
your summer making no money some people
love kids so you can't do that sure
they do
I love kids
but they're also for free time ideas if
it's my own kit but as soon as they're
like we're on skin they're like whoa no
no no no typically I'm not look I have
people who work with children especially
disadvantaged children they're Saints
they're great God bless you you're bad
apples I don't want to do it but I do
but I do think just like with the
priesthood there are there are
pedophiles there are predators oh yeah
because they know that's the who go
that's a great way for me to get mine
and they they get themselves in those
positions which is of course why you
have to have all kinds of backgrounds
let's just be straight up 100 here you
made it pretty easy for that pedophile
though skinny dipping all the [__]
time that's on you bro you think are you
playing with the kid now I'm blaming you
well I was only a decision I was nine
yeah but you kept skinny dipping dude
but I I didn't know I'm not I'm not an
adult Roger it wasn't like I was 28
years old in the pool I was 28 with a
shaved body oops oops forgot my bathing
suit
what do you got Jen
all right um all I'm saying is make it
more difficult yeah make it a little
more difficult how about this Ronnie
James suffers talking about him with uh
our boy during a USC workout USC workout
and there's like people talking about
certain things I'm sure you guys Elon
Musk came out and said like myocarditis
yeah
I did this one again I'm not an
anti-vaxxer I just think
is it okay to can we look into it like I
don't think you're anti-vector like we
have heard the mitochondria
is a side effect myocarditis just means
inflammation but yeah but it's a problem
like can we just I'm not saying that all
vaccines are bad can we just look into
it and you don't call me far right
anti-vaxxer is it okay to say that no
you can't is it is it weird that all
these athletes and young kids that a lot
of them have the common denominator that
they got the vaccine and they're having
issues now that's all right it saved a
lot of people's lives and there's a side
effect and this is one of them so I
don't know if you saw RFK Jr talking
about uh he was um in front of Congress
he goes I've got I got a flu vaccine
every year for 20 years all my kids are
vaccinated I've I stuck to every vaccine
he said I just didn't get the coven one
yeah correct and and he was asking
questions so
and then if a legit Doctor Who's not on
the left on the right comes out was like
we looked into it it's actually a
different condition that would help
everybody yes but to just be silent like
no no it's something else well that
ain't that ain't holding water anymore
you'll be transparent it says holding it
in water anymore you you guys that you
guys
kept my kids out of school for two years
and you ruin business after business
after business
and we'd like some answers we still
don't know the origin they take no
accountability that's the issue there's
no chance and and as a result [__] you
and [__] you twice that's horrible for
Rodney James and that's what kind of
really got me
anyway we won't talk about it no but for
brownies guys just keep in life he's
okay he just got the SC but you know if
he has a Harkins that could really
affect his career that's a bummer yeah
so he's out of ICU I think he's still in
the hospital out of intensive care and
uh there was a like a very you know
popular YouTube Doctor I'm not sure what
kind of doctor is he does a lot of MMA
stuff when people break their bones and
stuff like that he was saying that this
could potentially be a career Ender
unless they find exactly what that what
caused it and they can kind of like you
know regulate it but the problem is they
can't find it he's written here's the
prompt him we're in such a political
climate like let's say they're not going
to say it'd be the rare circumstance
where it was from the vaccine we will
never find that out they don't want to
admit to it so then this kid loses his
career because they don't want to admit
that maybe the vaccine did do this we
will never find out his family won't
find out because they know that would
blow the roof off the problem is maybe
he's the the outlier and he suffers from
this because of the vaccine he's outlier
doesn't mean the vaccine's bad he's just
the outlier they don't want that gift
the better way to say is this there are
a lot of scientists A lot of scientists
who are immunologists vaccinologists and
who are who study this
who would agree who would agree with
some of the things you're saying oh but
I'm saying I don't know yeah but let's
knock that off so you can because the
rights run and with this yeah which
isn't good the left is running with us
going no it's not that but if it was
transparent I think what somebody said
something when you say the science
you're saying it's all settled science
never settled so don't save the science
as if you have all the truth we are we
are learning as we go and stay open now
let's change subjects because I saw a
movie I want to talk about oh [__] and
it was a horrible taste oh you say
Barbie I did I it cracked me say that on
crowder let me know how it goes first
but it cracks but yeah really creative
and funny Ryan Gosling's hilarious put
your your [__] no no no I've heard the
stories about that show that like he's
pushing this weird not really no not
really they say it was like there is a
tree I saw some of the Barbies
definitely is but but but
and I have to say
look all stupid but they do but it's Ken
but I have to say it was super creative
and super funny and and people who were
up in arms about it it's the wrong fight
to have it was actually Super Creative
you it was it was actually hilarious and
really well done and weird and and smart
funny the movies for people like you
right right
that means for you no I'm telling you
there's a reason it's crushing at the
box office well of course every woman's
seen it but no but it's it's funny I'm
telling you it's funny she she's Margot
Robbie's the best movie star maybe ever
I mean she's incredible you know what
you are you're too hyper and and and our
boy bring up our boy bring up our boy's
body bring up Ken who's the Ken doll
look at his body but he's so funny in
this small guy hey small he's small no
no he's six foot no not even close what
no no Ryan Gosling yeah everybody and
dancing [__] like that Bob every bit of
six I bet she's not even six foot on
Wikipedia on Google how tall do you
think he is five nine oh come on you got
to give me more than that Bubba he's got
I don't think so I think he's six feet
nice and shredded right I'm a fan oh I
love him in la la land that's his best
performance you got to see him that's
real town I won't see this Brian so I'm
not coming you guys let me ask you this
though who'd you go with didn't go with
your buddies did you I don't know you
went with your skinny dipping buddies
right no I no no who'd you go with no
other guys right come on women be cool
bro women my lady and and a couple
friend of ours the girls were the ones
who took us there there you go and they
dressed in pink look bro
you're like that was I know men say this
movie's bad but it's so good right
creative Barbie bro be cool man I I just
went to see it with some people and yeah
there were a lot of a lot of girls there
yeah and you didn't want to see
Oppenheimer I did want to see
Oppenheimer but bro cause you could have
saw Oppenheimer which is history or Barb
come on be cool man just see the please
see the movie you know what it would
take so much like I want to see
Oppenheimer
I only go to the movies with my kids man
so until it comes out on demand I don't
see anything I mean sure as [__] not
Barbie you [__]
no and then you're trying to pitch no
please the rest of us to see it now guys
please just hear me out goddamn
government guys no hear me out listen
it's a very funny movie
and it's hard it's hard to you know it's
hard to argue with that kind of
creativity
it's crushing it's crushing dude
it's crushing
I didn't see Super Mario Brothers
well my kids love that movie I think the
movie's great
and Will Ferrell's in it he's hilarious
yeah I'm not seeing it dude bro please I
only have so many hours in the day I'm
not wasting my life no I've never liked
Barbie no I know I haven't either I
wouldn't have seen it but I'm glad I did
you're a gay man dude I've never seen
and one of these things like Barbie
takes it from both sides takes it from
the feminist takes it from the the other
the girls like both sides
an oppenheimer's three hours long I'm
out that's a long one yeah I hear very
good though I heard so good yeah Robert
Downey Junior's trip came out was like
this is the best movie out there do you
know what it's about yeah
came up with the the bomb that dropped
[__] underground yeah
yeah it's a Manhattan I mean you're not
hang out with your project dumb friends
that's all Barbie you know I'm not
really even about you see Barbie though
I just want to make sure you knew and
you know I think Barstow posted a map of
the cities that more people saw
oppenheim and the Barbie that's how I'm
like oh those are educated cities
if you have this choice between
Oppenheimer and Barbie yeah that's how
you know you talk right no no Barbie was
shockingly hey the [__] up do this on
crowder
do it to Crowder please louder please
light them up August I'm not on until
August 7th but we'll get on there I'll
be good for you dude do it on there yeah
I'm gonna bring that up because you know
it's gonna bring up on Roku because the
right the right can't stand the movie
because they talk about the patriarchy
and stuff but they just they're not
they're not it's not the fight to have
it's not the hill to die on
well you're dying on a hilly pieces what
do we got here now hold on what's this
oh what's this chin make sure you delete
all that of course so your boy both of
your friends uh well you're friends with
Donald Cerrone yes and I guess dude this
is old news Cerrone came on fight
campaign said he wants to fight Andrew
he said uh Kurt uh he said uh Joe
Schilling's been trying to fight him
forever but he always like ran from
those two so let me play this real quick
this is Adam 22 and uh Aiden Ross and
they're talking to uh Andrew Tate here
and there's Andrew or wait what do you
call it is this reason this is not that
real seven years ago hanging out with
the UFC fighter Donald cowboy Cerrone
and he pulled up some old Andrew tape uh
kickboxing matches on the companion
that's what he's talking about and did a
pretty good job of making the point why
not give me credit I'd like to see my
record stands for itself that was on my
show he ate fights four-time world
champion I fought a bunch of rules
including MMA and I'm very confident in
my abilities as for Cerrone didn't
McGregor finish him pretty quick he
thinks I can't fight then if he wants to
tell me to my face and kick my ass he's
welcome to try and I strongly believe he
would regret that decision and that's as
far as I need to take it listen I like
Andrew Taylor people making fun friends
boxing record or something like that I
mean strongly [__] him up don't get it
twisted for throwing [__] Andrew Tate up
and I think surprise just going after
him because he's so famous like they
wouldn't be going after me he wasn't
this big big name but I know Joe Schoen
was trying to fight him for years yeah
he just you know no just never happened
you don't want a part of Joe showing you
you don't want to party you don't want
your cowboy and chilling you don't want
them problems with those guys I'm Andrew
who gives a [__] I'm like who said okay
yeah also it's such a bad example though
didn't he get knocked out by Conor
McGregor what yeah Connor yeah yeah yeah
he did though yeah like Joe showing he
didn't fight like you look at his record
you see the guys they fought you know it
is what it is yeah but but Tate legit
legit fighter yeah yeah
so Donald Cerrone made this video
yesterday so where is Andrew Stone House
Arrest over there he's doing yes wait
what'd you say interviews he's in house
arrest doing interviews from Romania yep
he's got big problems
he's got some big problems I think uh
that that that that is a real
I I am not optimistic about his
is I am because the girl that did it
came out and said that they were of
course didn't do it and got paid so that
helps them out did they say that
recently uh no that's been out for a
while because this document this this
the guy you watching do you watch this
after Barbie no it's god dog who are you
brother I think Andrew's in a lot of
trouble go see Barbie guys
wow dude that's that's it fire him but
Crowder fire your friend no dude please
he's going against Andrew Tay and he
wants you to he's promoting Barbie think
of your life right now
dude please I'm just in a lot of trouble
you're you're here
hot right now please I mean until she's
in a lot of trouble
it's just that Romania [__] you stop
turning me into a power bottom I'm just
I'm just saying bro let me just be cool
be cool you're you're heated up right
now your jets are fired they're firing
on all cylinders I forgive you with the
skinny dip stuff and then this look bro
I'm just I'm feeling a little sensitive
right now like look I'm just saying he's
in a lot of trouble oh really what
article did you read serious problems
he's not though if you no you know if
you've found it he now listen the
Romania government is crooked as [__]
and he would be let out anywhere else in
the world if he's American he's fine
Romania I don't know how it works out
there yeah he needs to get the [__] out
of there if they do let him out he'll be
fine well the stuff he was saying on
back in the day there's of how he would
do these things that's what's going to
be used against him right but the girls
that came out said they were paid
they're on record saying they were paid
and told to say that okay and those are
the two examples they have to hold them
down that has been out for six months
bro
this is the most recent thing that came
out
yeah but think about all the Rolling
Stones so yeah don't click on Rolling
Stones no don't click on Rolling Stones
don't do any of it like any of this main
stuff all and what are you on Google so
it's owned by the left so all the left
hates it so all this is gonna be
negative stuff at Andrew take yes
if you guys want to educate yourself you
got to go deep on it and you got to
really look into the nitty-gritty of it
you can't just Google and you take
because of the media who hates the guy
it's going to pop up the War Stories
you [__] [__]
all right yeah oh I Google I wrote
Rolling Stones man they say screws
that's I feel like I don't talk that way
dude come on man be cooler I'll have to
knife you and I don't want to knife you
all right
I don't know Bubba he's got to get
whatever when you bring up Google yeah
if you read that he has issues and
Trump's getting arrested you dumbass
you're that guy what no bro Trump's
going to prison yes oh is he no don't
how do I say it Trump's still under
prison go see Barbie
no dude don't don't do that I'm not
that's not how I talk bro I talk like
this
all right it's tough because the waters
are so murky because this side hates
them this side loves them so the water
is so murky it's tough to figure out
what is it it's always tough to find out
what's really he has so much influence
and he's going against the Matrix you
don't know what that is
you're in it what do you mean you
promote it I mentioned Barbara's
actually very good it's very educational
for women I didn't say that that's not
the part I said bro the only thing that
movie's missing is Amy Schumer it would
be an A plus if Amy Schumer I never said
that dude please
is lizzo in it no she's not no I'm
pretty sure they offered a role yeah
well
yeah and the director was very funny
uh let me see this
sure Georgie
so this is a sweet story uh this lady
when she was a teenager her father was
arrested for a violent crime and when
she got married recently she had the
arresting officer walk her down the
aisle was the crime against her or the
model it was just in general violent
crime
well that's a good man right she is also
in law enforcement now ah this story
kind of makes me sad so hold on she had
the me too the cop who put her father
away in prison walking down the aisle so
she doesn't have a dad it makes me want
to cry right now I don't know why
weddings here
please please do that okay I feel like
crying right now you like crying Barbie
when Ken Johnson no I like Barbie
there's just too much Ken oh he was a
break she the cop arrested her abusive
father oh there you go story then there
you go that's a note we could have used
your sage no we could have used George
that's on me abusing abusive father that
makes sense yeah man I'm all cucked up
right I thought that I thought the dad
was like he got arrested because he's
trying to feed the family rob the bank
because the kids were starving like good
dad you put him away she invites him to
the wedding I didn't know the dad was
abusing the kids yeah this is a great
story then yeah yeah
my apology she got a wagon oh let me see
that's a wagon bro look I can talk like
oh my God you guys skin passes look look
he's got a wagon doesn't feel right man
hey go skinny dip with your friends nah
bro
what else you got Jen this one's okay so
remember the most recent one we saw was
Jonah Hill and his ex texts or releasing
text messages yeah so baby rexa she's
been
a lot of times she says she gets a lot
of hate about people complaining about
her weight how she gains weight and this
and that so she had a super truck so she
put her man on she put her she and she
broke it with him apparently okay just
so everybody knows when you do this once
every other guy if they're smart goes
I'm not dating that girl
well I think it should be all right so
batty and she's talented she's so like
like a week or a few weeks ago she put
this out on the internet and everyone
was on her side because like how could
he say something about her weight right
what did he say though so we'll show you
the text here
so now fans rally behind the
ex-boyfriend here's the text hey I never
said you were beautiful I never said I
didn't love you in fact I said how
beautiful you are and how much I loved
you but I always said I would be honest
with you and your and your face was
changing
you asked because I care would you
rather I lie to you you gained 35 pounds
obviously you gain weight and your face
changes should I just pretend it didn't
happen and that's okay come on I gained
three pounds and you call me chubs and
fat doesn't mean you don't love me if
you're trying to find reasons to break
up this makes sense but it's not the
real reason if you're unhappy with me
yourself uh with life and don't see a
future with us then it's okay and that's
the reason don't use something like that
to weaponize your angering or anxiety or
any insecurities you may have you know I
always found you to be beautiful and
loved you no matter what I think it's
important for you to think about things
and write things down speak to a
therapist and do this retreat thing to
get to the root of the problem let me
know if you'd like to speak if you need
more clarity love you that's a guy
that's a good guy yeah fat shaming works
too and she put that did she she put
that to uh yeah she put that you thought
people were like yeah girl go but
everyone's like oh this guy sounds like
what a nice guy
but it was on her Instagram story but I
mean she's the one that asked like to
tell
her she shared text message of him
letting her know that she's getting a
little weight too much weight after she
asked him she's like yes I started
gaining weight but bring up the pictures
how much weight did she get in because
she died she's always been curvy dude
I'll find Kirby too yeah let me see let
me there's something that's him with her
right there okay I'm a huge fan of that
right I'm a huge fan calm down Barbie
yeah all right
again there she's she's absolutely hot
as [__]
a little bigger there why I have no
problem with that there you go I have
absolutely no problem no there you go
but but but by the way if she gained a
lot of weight yeah okay because she
probably has weight swings if she did I
get it she says she has some sort of
condition ovary conditions it's called
overeating yeah look at her there oh no
she's bad as [__] bro yeah there's no
problems here we have no problems here
but um but if if she I was a lot thin
and I did gain some weight that comes
the territory I'm not mad about it
because it's true but when you see
things like that it does mess with you
you know what somebody's going through
and what they're going through in life
so it's kind of tough but I feel like in
2023 we should not be talking about
people's weight you told him to tell him
no this is before she's always been
saying stuff about people complaining
about her weight like every guy knows if
your girl asks you if these pants look
good or if I look you lie in these you
say no you always lie you're not gonna
get you're not going to get anywhere by
telling the truth
she has a cystic ovary syndrome no you
don't no you don't and that's not what
that's not why you have uh why you're
gaining weight because she has the hit
single called bad [__] you're taking a
lot of uh calories but I think she's hot
so
yeah she's hot and I got no problem
because I literally hold on go up 10. no
no no no
I literally jumped 30 pounds so quickly
maybe a little bit more but maybe a
little bit more let me jumped 40. uh but
we just got to be positive and just show
people love yeah dude but you asked him
he was like you put a little weight on
your face but by the way I got moon face
girl yeah and I if you did that yeah
moon face 30 pounds is uh that's a lot
well and she says three pounds that
means 40 pounds yeah she's like five
five that's a lot of work that's a lot
of oh that'll change it that'll change
you and then he was like hey baby you
told me to say something I'm fat some
people carry it in their face maybe yeah
where do you put your weight on
your face
and dick
face dick face lucky I'm facing day my
dick gets so fat I love girls who are
like she's cutting my boobs and butt
that's well I'll go eat up yeah carb up
you know this girl's they're a girl
there are girls like that you're like
Jesus Christ yeah my girl I know all my
weight goes to my butt yeah my girl
she's like oh my God me and it just goes
my butt and titties eat up girl yep
my girls I gained five pounds but if my
but even my girls like you let me know
if I'm getting some weight I'll Never
sing yeah I don't see it
if she gained 30 pounds
we're gonna I gotta you gotta move out
well my friend my friends my friends
no I do I go hey your bags are packed
right my friends my friends Dad's
girlfriend
I'll tell you later
she was he was older of course and she
was 40
and um
and she he goes he said he goes I don't
like having sex with her anymore my
buddy's like why Dad and he goes she's
got a belly it's disgusting stuff she
had a belly she put her weight on in her
belly so she had a because she drank a
lot most people oh yeah I just can't
have sex with her should we farting too
yeah I don't mind if it goes to your
butt and but but when it goes to your
belly it's a little bit for me this it
could be making me tough well there's
also some of those women who are like
they put on 120 pounds like it's after
the base the baby weight I'm like held
your kid 12. well
well yeah
I'm gonna say something 12 years I'm
gonna say something that's gonna sound a
little bit mean but I'm just gonna say
it so I I have no problem with weight I
like you see a girl sometimes and she
might be what you would consider
overweight and I if she's if it's if
she's just curvy like in the right place
yeah I'm in I don't know I prefer that
yeah I like it but um there was a girl
who I felt that way about and then
like there is a thing when if somebody
is a little too overweight and they lie
down
yeah they can tend to look different it
expands yes and that's through here well
all the stuff holding it up that throat
oh God that threw me off that was like
wow you you know that that that really
kind of goes out east to west there yeah
that was interesting but overall I got
no problem beauty is not a Beholder dude
huh Beauty's in you know teach their own
like you know but it's like you know
people don't know when the steamroller
hit in the cartoon goes over yeah the
cartoon the Road Runner and you're like
whoa
I tell you where all right let's let's
keep going I don't want to be mean uh
this might be the last one so with that
girl that we talked about many times
already Colleen Russell there you go she
finally admitted guilt that she made
everything up uh-huh and she still
doesn't there's no like emotive for yet
but uh this is what she said
the press conference Monday attorneys
saying that their client admitted to
lying about the events July 13th through
the 15th everything from seeing a
toddler on the side of uh i-459 being
abducted by a white man classic with
orange hair okay and even uh in general
is a lie I know they're like what
Russell meant she didn't have any help
in acting alone but her motive for
staging her own kidnapping has not been
yet revealed yeah I'd love to hear why I
also read that she said in the statement
that she the guy that kidnapped her him
and another female accomplice were
taking pictures of her naked
and then since this happened her
boyfriend are now potentially her
ex-boyfriend put this out on Instagram
uh so Carly's actions created hurt
confusion and dishonestyles so does she
do it just to cover up maybe she said
naked pictures that's the only thing I
can think of yeah too much girl too much
so he seems out of jail for this yeah I
wonder what what legal because with the
cops involved all that yeah like a big
Manhunt I don't think there's a big
Manhunt but yeah so her boyfriend didn't
know what was going on no there's her
family and her boyfriend believed
everything but now her boyfriend's like
yeah he's out no longer a boyfriend
yeah probably get asked to pay back the
money from the investigation Maybe
yeah I don't know what I mean yeah she's
like a new prison enough for that right
the cop's like yeah
the internet's gonna take care of this
one her boyfriend's a handsome dude did
Jesse Malay do prison time
no nothing homeboys he got community
service I think
and then his career got ruined yeah he's
got Style
small guy
uh can can you look up uh how tall no
Ryan Gosling yeah let's go stuck on
Barbie yeah I just want to see because
I'm I'm I'm so impressed with this
accident yeah he's six feet above well
that means five ten I don't know Bob
about six feet let's see if he's next to
any other celebrities yes uh there he is
with oh boy I suppose every bit of six
two damn she's wearing heels look at his
boots who is that girl that's that one
girl she's a name with uh Ben Affleck
for a little while yeah she's great
Jesus
Eva Mendes also Eva Manda is six foot
two then she's got heels on though he's
way in front of her he's pretty tall and
he has boots on I'd say he's my height
Bo
o I think he's five you're not six foot
either yeah but
if I really stand up tall
all right Anna to armas she's legit
she's Marilyn Monroe because that's Jon
Hamm right
no that's Chris Evans I mean he seems
pretty tall he's definitely not sure
you've never seen her before Jesus
Christ dude she's and she started
Marilyn Monroe on Netflix she's great in
that yeah
uh
he he's a real loner he kind of keeps to
himself well we don't know that but hey
go see Barbie Brian recommends it no no
no he's very funny in that
guys
uh ice house this weekend 40 tickets
left Ice House Pasadena shop and friends
this Friday we have cow bass's fight
campaign this Saturday for UFC 291 we
got Cheeto Vera we got Bradley Martin
the boys are coming out tune in live
thick boy YouTube only 7 P.M Pacific
time that is live uh Phoenix Arizona
stand up live one night two magical
shows I'll be at JT's wings during the
day you can find my fat ass there
Phoenix Arizona August 11th Omaha
Nebraska August 16th Kansas City
Missouri August 17th Liberty Township
Ohio have no clue where that's at August
30th Columbus Ohio August 31st get your
tickets every time
it's it's near Cincinnati oh gotcha yeah
uh briancallen.com for tickets I will be
at the Ontario Improv not in Canada but
in the Inland Empire uh Friday Saturday
get your tickets Ontario Improv and then
I got Austin cap cities August 345 and
I'm excited about that and we're doing
fight command with Rogan next week in
Austin yes sir you might be there for a
little bit I'll try God bless all right
kids love you